salut c'est hugo et j'espère que vous
allez bien on est parti pour un nouveau
programme d'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser à dix mesures portées par
philippe poutou le candidat du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste un parti classé à
l'extrême gauche à noter que comme pour
tous les candidats cette vidéo
s'accompagne d'une interview du candidat
l'interview face cachée de philippe
poutou est en l'occurrence déjà sorti
sur cette chaîne youtube c'est la
première du coup n'hésitez pas à la
découvrir si ça vous intéresse
alors d'abord qui est philippe poutou il
a 54 ans alors 55 ans mais vous regardez
cette vidéo après le 14 mars et la
politique ce n'est pas son métier à
temps plein même s'il a commencé à
militer très jeunes non diplômés il a
fait la majeure partie de sa carrière
comme ouvrier dans l'entreprise de
voitures ford de blanquefort près de
bordeaux et comme d autres ouvriers il
s'est fait licencier en 2009 après la
fermeture de son usine il est
aujourd'hui donc au chômage et en
parallèle conseiller municipal à
bordeaux c'est donc sa troisième
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
après 2012 et 2017 où il avait obtenu à
l'époque à chaque fois un peu plus d'un
pour cent des suffrages soit environ 400
mille voix alors pour cette présentation
du programme de philippe poutou ça me
semble déjà important avant d'aller sur
10 mesure de commencer par ce qui est
l'idée plus générale de son programme
elle est absolument centrale dans ce
qu'il propose philippe poutou veut
sortir complètement du capitalisme donc
ce système économique qui existe en
france et dans une bonne partie du monde
et qui repose notamment sur la propriété
privée et sur l'économie de marché selon
lui nous sommes dans une société de plus
en plus inégalitaire avec une très
grande misère sociale face à une
catastrophe écologique
et c'est la preuve selon lui que le
modèle capitaliste en place aujourd'hui
ne fonctionne pas du coup ils souhaitent
contre très fortement avec toutes les
politiques actuelles et vous allez le
voir ça donne des mesures qui sont
beaucoup plus radicale disons que la
plupart des autres candidats à la
présidentielle et qui implique plus
largement en fait au delà de ces mesures
qu'on va évoquer un véritable changement
de système concrètement ça passe d'abord
par cette première mesure par exemple
que l'état reprenne contrôler des
secteurs clés de l'économie ça vaut pour
les banques les transports la
communication les industries
pharmaceutiques etc etc c'est des
éléments qui sont aujourd'hui donc géré
par des entreprises privées deuxième
mesure philippe poutou souhaite que tout
le monde en france gagne au moins 1800
euros net par mois selon lui c'est
vraiment le montant minimal pour pouvoir
se loger et se nourrir correctement
s'habiller cultiver ses passions et ses
concrètement pour les salariés les
fonctionnaires ça passe par une
augmentation du smic donc le salaire
minimum de 5 131 euros pour atteindre
1800 euros net par mois soit une hausse
de 42% c'est en l'occurrence la deuxième
plus forte hausse du smic de tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
juste derrière nathalie arthaud qui elle
souhaite un smic à 2000 euros net par
mois ensuite pour ceux qui ne
travaillent pas ça consiste en une
revalorisation de pas mal de choses
revalorisation du rsa du chômage des
retraites pour atteindre là aussi ce
même chiffre de 1800 euros net par mois
et enfin ce qui est très marquant ce
qu'il souhaite que ce revenu concerne
aussi les jeunes il souhaite donc que
toutes celles et ceux qui sont âgés de
16 à 25 ans puisse recevoir une
allocation d'autonomie d'un montant égal
à ce nouveau smic donc toujours 1800
euros net par mois alors face à ces
propositions on peut se demander comment
est-ce qu'il compte financer tout ça
dans son programme philippe poutou
explique qu'il veut financer cette
hausse des revenus et des allocations je
cite en prenant plus sur les profits et
donc ça implique par exemple de taxer
beaucoup plus fortement les plus riches
et les entreprises même s'il ne précise
pas forcément les modalités exactes dans
des tailles troisième mesure philippe
poutou veut diminuer le temps de travail
avec une idée affichée par son parti
l'idée de ne pas perdre sa vie à la
gagner
selon lui cette baisse du temps de
travail permettrait à la fois de mieux
répartir les emplois au sein de la
société mais aussi et bien que chacun
puisse profiter davantage de la vie pour
ça il veut d'abord baissé le ton travail
hebdomadaire en passant à une semaine de
4 jours avec 28 heures de travail par
semaine contre 35 heures sur cinq jours
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui et ce
sans que les salaires
soit diminuée philippe poutou veut
également introduire une sixième semaine
de congés payés pour les salariés et
dans cette même idée donc de diminuer le
temps de travail philippe poutou veut
qu'on passe moins d'années à travailler
il veut donc abaissé l'âge de départ à
la retraite de deux ans pour passer à 60
ans comme le propose notamment jean luc
mélenchon mais lui avec le besoin de
cotiser seulement 37 ans contre 40 ans
pour mais l'enfant au passage donc selon
philippe poutou et plus généralement
selon les candidats qui sont favorables
à la réduction du temps de travail je le
disais une telle mesure permettrait
aussi de réduire le chômage en
répartissant mieux le travail au sein de
la société si une mesure qui est
fortement contestée en l'occurrence par
la droite vers les pécresse par exemple
souhaite al'inverse allonger la durée de
temps de travail et estiment que réduire
le temps de travail rend les entreprises
françaises moins compétitive par rapport
à d'autres entreprises à l'étranger ce
qui pourrait donc avoir selon elle un
impact négatif sur le nombre d'emplois
en france quatrième mesure désormais
philippe poutou qui a lui même donc
était licencié en 2019 de son usine
woeth interdire les licenciements
concrètement il veut que dans une usine
par exemple et bien même c'est un
ouvrier à moins de travail parce que l'
usine produit - eh bien ils continuent à
être payé pareil et si l'entreprise
change sa production ou autre il ya une
souhaite que l'entreprise soit obligé de
trouver un autre travail dans une autre
branche ou dans une autre entreprise
pour ce salarié est ce donc sans pouvoir
mettre fin à son contrat de travail
allez cinquième mesure désormais à une
mesure assez marquante philippe poutou
souhaite détruire larmes nucléaire
française en effet il souhaite une
société démilitarisé sans armes et donc
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas que pour la
france qu'il souhaite ça c'est donc une
réflexion qui est plus global il veut
également que la france cesse toutes ses
opérations militaires à l'étranger il
souhaite aussi que la france sorte de
toutes les alliances militaires dont
elle fait partie ça vaut par exemple
pour l'otan et enfin philippe poutou
veut mettre fin aux ventes d'armes à des
pays étrangers alors que aujourd'hui
bien la france est le troisième
exportateur mondial d'armes 6ème mesures
qui concernent l'environnement désormais
philippe poutou veut atteindre 100%
d'énergies
renouvelables en france en 2050 et le
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste souhaite également
démantelé et exproprier les groupes
pétroliers ou encore les banques qui
subventionne assez extraction de pétrole
et de gaz 7e mesure philippe poutou veut
rendre les transports en commun
totalement gratuit pour tout le monde et
les développer pour que en fait il est
davantage de lignes même si en
l'occurrence c'est bien dans son
programme il ne chiffre pas précisément
une telle mesure 8e mesure maintenant
philippe poutou veut ouvrir les
frontières pour que la france accueille
tous les migrants qui désirent ils venir
le tout donc sans aucune distinction il
souhaite également régulariser tous les
sans papiers c'est une position qui est
partagé aussi par nathalie arthaud donc
la candidate du parti lutte ouvrière et
qui s'oppose à beaucoup de positions
d'autres candidats l'exact opposé disons
d'une telle mesure c'est par exemple la
position d'eric zemmour qui soutient
notamment la proposition de construction
de murs aux frontières de l'union
européenne
la 9e mesure c'est l'allongement du
délai légal pour avorter il souhaite le
porter à 24 semaines après le début de
la grossesse donc jusqu'à cinq mois et
demi alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'à
12 semaines maximum il veut également
rendre possible la procréation
médicalement assistée pour tous les
coups enfin 10e mesure avant les mesures
en bref cette fois ci elle est liée à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire s'il est
élu philippe poutou veut mettre fin aux
passes vaccinale et investir massivement
dans le système de santé il affirme
vouloir embaucher 200 milles personnel
hospitalier et ouvrir 100 mille lits
supplémentaires en france en s'attachant
notamment à rouvrir des hôpitaux dans
les zones rurales et enfin philippe
poutou veut absolument que tous les
soins soient remboursés à 100% pour tout
le monde et interdire la possibilité
pour les médecins de faire des
dépassements d'honoraires qui va
permettre donc de faire payer plus que
ce qui est remboursé par la sécurité
sociale alors pour terminer je vous
lister quelques autres mesures que
philippe poutou souhaite mettre en place
il souhaite accorder le droit de vote
aux étrangers à toutes les élections en
france il souhaite rembourser à 100% les
parcours de transition et de changement
d'état civil
pour toutes les personnes trans sur
simple demande et enfin pour terminer
pour lutter contre la grande pauvreté
philippe poutou veut que tous les
logements qui ne sont pas occupés en
france soient réquisitionnés et est
utilisé pour loger les sans abri voilà
même pour ce qui est du programme de
philippe poutou sachant que comme j'ai
dit en début de vidéo c'est un projet
aussi qui est plus global de sortie
complète du capitalisme ce qui implique
forcément énormément de choses on ne
cache jamais voulu en savoir plus je
vous invite à voir l'interview de
philippe poutou que j'ai réalisé donc il
ya quelques jours je vous mets le lien
directement description mais c'est
disponible aussi directement sur cette
chaîne de la même façon je mets cette
élection présidentielle vous intéresse
vous allez découvrir donc sur cette
chaîne youtube dans les prochains jours
les décryptages des programmes et les
interviews des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
du coup n'hésitez pas à vous abonner je
ne sais pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes encore une
fois on verra dans les prochains jours
si philippe poutou arrive à atteindre
les 500 parrainages pour être
officiellement candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je crois j'ai tout dit
prudent de vous pour résoudre vos
proches et on se dit à très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo